if I could evening members officers of
the council members of the press in
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council Thursday 6 of September 2018
housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs either through the security
doors
to my right or opposite the lifts in the
foyer
please do not use the lifts there's only
one working at the moment so don't rush
for it please assemble in Hawley square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening thank you if any member of
the public who objects to the
possibility of being filmed may wish to
take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and that they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
in the chamber whilst the meeting is in
progress end of lesson
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councilors Jeremy Fairbrass Evans Fenner
Hillman Martin shank Dumas Merson
Venables Wells and day are there any
other apologies councillor Piper Thank
You chairman councillor Roy Potts
thank you sorry Thank You chairman Kelso
talent agenda item two minutes of the
previous meeting held on the 12th of
July 2018 with members please note that
there is a typographical error in item
six a question for the public regarding
clinical waste it should state that it
was councillor Taylor Smith who
responded to that particular question so
subject to this amendment I move that
the minutes of the meeting of the
council held on the 12th of July 2018 be
approved and signed as a correct record
with the vice chairman please second
second chair do members agree thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 19th
of July 2018 I move that the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting of the council
held on 19th of July 2018 be approved
and signed as a correct record with the
vice chairman please second second chair
do members agree thank you agenda item 4
is announcements I have not received or
been informed of any announcements for
this evening with the exception that I
think we should welcome newly elected
councillor Linda Wright who's a past
incumbent of this council so welcome
back
council right
gender item five declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interests gender item six petitions one
petition has been received in accordance
with the council procedure rule number
12 and that is agenda item six a
petition regarding Jackie Baker's a
petition containing seventy valid
signatures has been received by the
council
unfortunately the petition organiser
most Taylor is unable unavailable to
assent the petition in person therefore
in accordance with the council petition
scheme the petition will be referred to
cabinet without debate and reported back
to the council within three ordinary
meetings councillors who are keeping a
watchful eye on this situation will know
that the work is already in hand so
that's that's good news agenda item
seven questions from the press and
public no questions have been received
from the press or the public so we can
move on to agenda item 8 questions from
members of the council for questions
have been received from members agenda
item 8 a question number 1 from the
member regarding the number of staff at
the council I call upon councillor
Johnson thank you very much chairman and
thank you leader tannic District Council
is a major employer or in sanity and
peace could the leader confirm the
numbers of staff with a breakdown for
each department thank you
yeah Thank You chair Thank You
councillor Johnson I'm happy to give you
these numbers CDC currently employs 483
staff which is the equivalent of for 151
point one six full-time equivalents in
the chief executive director at there
are six staff which is five point zero
for full-time equivalents corporate
governance directorates 58 staff forty
six point seven nine full-time
equivalents deputy chief executive in
section one five one Directorate 106
staff ninety eight point four seven
full-time equivalents operational
commercial services Directorate 258
staff 247 point six six full-time
equivalents and instant service is fifty
five staff fifty three point two zero
full-time equivalents Thank You leader
Kelso Johnson do you have a
supplementary question yes sorry I did
send my supplementary to the leader on
the 17th of August so he has had prior
knowledge of my question three points
really how many staff have been made
redundant since June 2015 - how many are
presently or recently involved in
tribunals with TDC and number three how
many have been dismissed thank you I
call upon the leader yeah Thank You
councillor Johnson as an experienced
counselor you will know that these
issues are the responsibility of the
head of paid service so I suggest that
you write to the chief executive
requesting the information you want
thank you thank you
general item 8b question number two from
the member regarding homeless families I
call upon counselor Constantin Thank You
chair I wish to bring to the council's
attention the 71 homeless families
referenced before to inquire after their
progress could the cabinet member give
me an update on the progress being made
to rehouse these 71 homeless panic
families currently in temporary
accommodation thank you I call upon the
councilor game to respond council game
Thank You chair at the council meeting
on the 12th of July I reported that
there were 71 families with children
living in temporary accommodation
arranged by the council we are working
hard to ensure that all households
living in temporary accommodation are
supported to move to a permanent home as
quickly as possible and keep the
position under constant review by August
2018 we had successfully supported 14 of
these 71 families to move to a permanent
home in addition a further 12 families
have a property identified for a planned
move during July and August we have had
to provide temporary accommodation for
31 new families with children who had
approached the council for assistance
I'll just point out that that pip that
figure does actually fluctuate week by
week during the same six-week period we
have also successfully reduced the total
number of households living in temporary
accommodation by over 12 percent down
from 168 on the 9th of July to 147 on
the 23rd of August within these figures
we have particularly focused on reducing
the council's use of hotel accommodation
this type of accommodation is both the
most expensive and the least suited to
the needs of homeless households the
council reduced the use of hotel
accommodation by half done from 51
households to 26 households by 30th of
June by the 23rd of August this had
reduced to
- and I'll point out there are no
children in those families we have set
out a plan to reduce the council's use
of temporary accommodation to 90
households by the end of the financial
year a reduction of 50% from the
position at the end of 2017 we shall see
this ambition realized if the reasons
but recent performance is maintained
provided demand for the service does not
increase further during the first four
months since the introduction of
homelessness reduction Act on the 3rd of
April we received 789 referrals to the
service and completed 303 personal
housing plans there are two thousand
five hundred and forty-two households on
housing register and in housing need and
our landlord lives and officers are
working with 432 active cases where the
council has either a prevention or a
relief duty under this act the demand
for the service is unprecedented however
despite these pressures we have both
increased our success in preventing
homelessness and reduced the council's
use of temporary accommodation
representatives from the Ministry of
Housing communities and local government
government visited the service to
discuss the council's response to the
introduction of the new Act this visit
was followed up with a letter confirming
how impressed they were with the
progress that has been made so far this
year there is more to do and who remain
committed prevents it committed to
preventing homelessness and reducing our
use of temporary accommodation the
long-term solution to the crisis we face
is more affordable homes to rent the
council therefore continues to invest in
building new homes investing 30 million
to deliver 150 new homes by 2020 we
expect to complete 20 homes during the
current financial year and construction
is progressing well with a further 49
home is due to start over the same
period and I've just heard that we have
just submitted a bid for a further 35
new homes
at a total cost of 8.8 million the work
that has been completed to prevent
homelessness construct new homes and
support people living in temporary
accommodation has improved the outcomes
for homeless people and is helping to
manage the overall costs of homelessness
for the council's this is not just an
issue in sanity I would like us all to
work together and support our housing
team in their commitment to prevent
homelessness and reducing the use of
temporary accommodation this should not
be a political point-scoring issue but a
case of all parties working together for
Thanet okay Thank You Kelsey gay
Callison constantine do you have a
supplementary question thank you Thank
You council again for very comprehensive
answer I think that is really good
progress especially when you consider
local authorities have been cut to the
tune of 49 percent since the Tory
government came in in 2010 but my
question is can you tell me how you're
using the Human Rights Act as a
framework to avoid splitting up families
or to make youngsters in the area less
vulnerable to being split up from their
families and being housed
inappropriately thank you council game
thank you we take the Human Rights Act
very seriously and wherever possible we
try our hardest not to split families
well under the new homeless reduction
act we have a personal plan which we
develop with the families and I simply
try our hardest as you know I have asked
to meet with you so that we can work
together on this and we can look at
those points at our meeting I look
forward to it thank you
Thank You council game
agenda item 8c question number 3 from a
member regarding the summer kitchen
I call upon counselor metaphase Thank
You chair I have a very short preamble
if I may the summer kitchen was the
brainchild of Sharon Goodyear
who was concerned that children who got
school meals could lose out in the
holidays using food donated by
supermarkets close to their use-by date
contributions from farmers from Fanny
earth allotments and gleaned from
orchards over 1,800 meals were served to
families couples singles and groups at
Draper's Mills school and Newington so
my question to councilor Beaufort is
following the success of the summer
kitchen in uniting the community and
helping many disadvantaged families will
fanic District Council be applying for
money from the government next year
similar to the funds announced by
children and families Minister Nadine
Sahar we to enable the scheme to
continue here thank you
I call upon the leader thank you so much
thank you for your question councillor
must face this was initially a TDC
initiative to provide fit and fed
sessions in mill made and EWTN's and
during the summer holidays East Kent
housing provided funding and we
commissioned your leisure to deliver the
scheme now kitchen were able to secure
further funding from house the Barry
Lewis to enhance a service that could be
provided across the summer these types
of project often known as fitting fed of
something which TDC first ran in 2017 in
partnership with the zone youth project
in Broadstairs in that case TDC provided
the fit element and the project provided
the fed our active Thanet strategic
framework outlines how we will be
delivering and commissioning sports and
public health activities in
collaboration with partners and as such
we will be looking to apply for suitable
funding for this type of project the fed
element of these successful projects is
something that we are trying to build
into as many of our suitable active
planet offerings as possible overall
this project has been a great success
and a good example of partnership
working we'll be continuing to work in
this way going forward in line with
their active Vanek strategic framework
at the current time it's not known if
the holiday activities and food Research
Fund will be available next year and who
will be eligible to apply but if it is
then we will be looking to apply to
continue this good work Thank You leader
councillor metaphase the other
supplementary question thank you I do
officer nor fit-and-flare dancer Peters
recreation ground very well because as
in my is in my ward I would like to ask
a counselor Beaufort if you'd be willing
to meet with me and we're sharing good
ears so we can discuss how we can get
the fed bit element absolutely in place
for next year
accounts the master phase of anything
you can be stressed too strongly the
good that these projects do and I'll be
delighted to come to that meeting no
problem thank you gender item 8d
question number four from a member of
regarding the new gate gap shelter
I call upon councillor Dawson councillor
Dawson Thank You mr. chair referred to
in my question has been withdrawn and
this is due to several objections for
members of the public concerning the new
gate gap shelter but I have not
withdrawn my question as this
application highlights exactly what
happens to our historic cultural
heritage when there was no plans
maintenance or repair work to structures
that are important part of our heritage
there are many examples of this across
than it and I'm sure many counselors
could name one in their ward the reality
of this and its consequences can be
summed up as the following no plans
maintenance equals plans dereliction and
it is not justified when groups such as
a better Cliftonville have struggled for
five years to get the fennec District
Council on side to save the shelter so
my question is TDC have neglected the
new gate gap shapes new shelter to the
point they now seek its part demolition
against the conservation of the suit
advice will you support and work with
the residents to save it in its entirety
this is important part of Clifton fields
heritage thank you
that wasn't a short preamble but it was
interesting information I call upon
councillor Gregory's or respondent
councillor Gregory yeah thank you German
I think it's fair to say that like all
of our Seaside shelters that they
probably don't get the maintenance that
that we
to have as a resident for Clifton vo I
obviously go past this shelter quite
frequently and and the roof is in a
shocking state there's no doubt about it
it's dangerous it's it's now surrounded
by harris fencing even that has been
pulled down and i came past there last
week after a council meeting in the dark
and there were people inside with
torches and you know so obviously
they're still getting in they're still
using it it's a real problem to the
council because it's a massive liability
to us because of the dangerous condition
it's in those members that have been
around as long as i have remember that
queens court residents used to complain
awful lot about what they saw going on
in that shelter and because of that you
know many years ago all of the inside
paneling was removed so that you could
see quite clearly what was going on
inside that shelter that of course had
the detrimental effect then of it not
being much of a shelter anymore because
the wind whistled through it but
nevertheless it's it's obviously yeah
part of our heritage is no doubt about
that now i haven't been involved with
this up until now because it was
operational services that have been
dealing with this which is not in my
portfolio but so that's not an excuse
I'm glad it's been brought to my
attention now and the thing is is that
it's the planning application that was
going in as I understand it was as a
result of conversations with the
officers and the community groups and it
was going to be turned into a usable
community space but it just wouldn't
have had the roof on it because somehow
or other we've got to sort out what
we're going to do about this dangerous
roof I know that the conservation
officer is against any debts or any form
of demolition and the Planning
Department had indicated that they
wouldn't have been prepared to to
approve the plans along those lines
anyway for that reason but since being
made aware of this I've made contact
with with Cliftonville groups and
there's a there's a new one in town at
the moment which is the save new gates
shelter it's a Facebook group and they
are having a meeting on Saturday at the
Olympia cafe which I'll be going along
to to see if I can you know sort of come
up with some constructive ways that we
can move forward and help them with this
now becoming as I understand it and
estates matters it's going to be part of
our asset management looking into this
so there will be we will be looking at
it from the point of view of if there's
any way we can look at community
transfer because obviously we don't have
the tens of thousands that is going to
cost to reinstate this shelter as it is
so yes absolutely
I am totally behind trying to find a way
that we can keep this shelter in some
form or another and I'll be meeting with
residents as well to were to try and
work out how we're going to do that
thank you thank you very much for the
extensive answer I'm sorry you didn't
elaborate on the earlier part of the
response councillor Dawson do you have a
supplementary question and can I ask you
to make it a question as you had quite a
extensive preamble rather than a
statement thank you what is the
maintenance budget for these assets
Thank You councillor Gregory are you
able to respond well you obviously
realize I don't have that information to
hand I mean we do have obviously a
strategic asset management plan which is
you know which everyone can read we are
the the States Department goes through
every asset we go over 700 assets and
many are of no benefit to the council at
all
we don't do I've an income we just have
liabilities and so obviously in the last
couple of weeks you've seen what's been
happening with Val Square and hearts
down and basically this is just the
council trying to unload assets that are
some sort of liability to the council
whether its financial or risk and
obviously every every asset is looked at
in the same way so from the point of
view of heritage actually assets the
same criteria would be applied to those
I don't know how many and I'm not sure
really what exactly what the question is
so perhaps I could ask councillor Dawson
if she would email me with her question
exactly and then I will certainly get
detailed answer to that thank you Thank
You councillor curry agenda item 9
motions of notes on notice no motions on
notice have been received in accordance
with the council procedure number
rule-free so we can move on to agenda
item 10 leaders report thank you
chairman I delivered my last leaders
report on the truth of July and by far
the most significant event since then
has been the adoption by this council of
a draft local plan this was published on
the 23rd of August from that date for
six weeks people have the opportunity to
comment on the draft these comments will
be presented to the planning inspector
who is appointed to examine the plan and
those who have commented will be invited
to make their points at a public inquiry
ultimately the inspector will decide if
our plan is suitable for adoption in its
present form or whether in the light of
his examination he would recommend
changes I cannot stress just how
important it is for people to make
representation whether in support or to
suggest changes that they believe would
improve the plan I must emphasize that
the plan as published is just a draft I
know that some of the content is
controversial with some issues being
very divisive I would urge anyone who
cares about than it and has a view to
make their thoughts known the local plan
is a blueprint for the ours future visit
important that when the plan is finally
adopted everyone can feel that it has
been subjected to a rigorous process
even if we might not agree with the
final outcome the local plan was our
number one priority when we took control
of TDC having dealt with that the next
major issue has to be addressing the
ongoing losses being made by the port
and harbor at Ramsgate to reflect the
importance of this issue I have taken on
the maritime portfolio and will oversee
the development of a new strategic
direction with its principal lines being
- firstly stem those losses and secondly
to generate a return from what should be
one of our most valuable assets I should
point out that although the accumulated
losses have recently been the subject of
great public interest they have in fact
been billed
over many years by several
administrations the Ramsgate site is
home to two businesses the marina in the
royal harbor which makes the profit and
pull Ramsgate which presently doesn't
not a detailed review is underway
looking at the breakdown of costs and
income from each to determine whether
there are any quick fixes that could be
actioned and perhaps more importantly
what long-term actions will be most cost
effective there is however a fundamental
dilemma at the heart of this situation
many of the people rightly wanting to
see a prompt financial turnaround are
against what they see as
commercialization of the pool favouring
instead some form of marina village
the fact is though that the fastest way
to improve cash flow would be the
introduction of a ferry operation the
council has been in negotiations with
the potential operator for some time now
and a new twist in the story is the fact
that it is now being thought that
Ramsgate could have a significant role
in the uk's post brexit resilience
planning offering an alternative route
for cross channel traffic should fears
of delays through the port of dover with
consequent road congestion be realized
certainly much greater clarity on this
matter will be required before a
strategy can be finalized and the
possible benefits weighed against other
options for the pool but I do believe
that this is not an either-or situation
and that in fact ultimately we could
have an improved marina a successful
ferry operation and potentially other
leisure retail and residential offerings
we recognized that in order to make
progress quickly expert help will be
required we already know what mdl are
well respected and marina consultancy
firm can offer we have also spoken to
other companies in the field who will be
visiting Ramsgate in the near future to
give us their thoughts on the way
forward after these visits we will go
through a thorough procurement process
before appointing a firm to advise us
along with many other parts of Ken
Thunder has suffered badly from travel
incursions this summer the problem has
been particularly bad at Jacky Baker's
and I'm pleased to report that works
have been undertaken to prevent a repeat
of recent events which caused such
distress to people
living nearby I'm sorry that because of
the special status accorded to travelers
TDC is unable to deal with their
antisocial behavior as quickly as we
would like recognizing the seriousness
of these illegal incursions hence police
and crime Commissioner has convened a
meeting of council leaders and senior
police officers to discuss the powers
that exist under present legislation and
how best to deploy them and TDC will be
represented at that meeting I can also
report that a premises closure order was
made on a problem property in Margate
which had been the source of significant
anti-social behavior we are determined
that we will not tolerate unacceptable
activities which exploit vulnerable
people and make those living nearby feel
unsafe when necessary we will always
take action we're all aware of how
important tourism is to Thanet with
millions of visitors coming to the
islets year fantastic weather experience
this year together with the tremendous
reputation their towns of building as
first-rate destinations as seen record
numbers of Ryan
this puts immense pressure on our
cleansing service especially around our
beaches
I believe full credits should be awarded
to our teens for coping so well this
summer we employed an extra 15 agency
staff and changed their working hours so
that they were cleaning on the beaches
and emptying bins up to 8 o'clock at
night and this has made a real
difference also in response to the much
increased volumes of litter an
additional 200 bins have been provided
across the district in a further
improvement to our visitor offering we
now provide Wi-Fi on all our main
beaches of Margate Broadstairs and
Ramsgate I'm also sure that members will
be pleased to learn that we've now
concluded a review of our public toilets
and over the coming weeks proposals for
improved provision will be coming
forward we would also be keeping the
toilets open until the end of September
and possibly longer depending on the
weather the House of Lords has pointed a
new select committee to consider the
regeneration of seaside towns and
communities this must inquire and report
by the end of March next year as part of
their evidence gathering there
in Margate later this month to see it
firsthand this revitalized town and to
question the members and officers about
the challenges we faced and how we
address them there will be particularly
interested in the turn of contemporary
and the culturally regeneration has
followed its establishment and I'm sure
that will also find the dream those
story fascinating finally I'm pleased to
report that the council has been
successful in achieving the South East
employers charter for an elected member
development the Charter mark indicates
that this council provides excellent
induction training and development for
its members and receiving it is the
culmination of 18 months of hard work
from both officers and members I would
like to take this opportunity to thank
everyone who's been involved however I
would particularly like to express our
thanks to Nick Hughes because without
his hard work energy and determination
this would not have been achieved
south-east employers were particularly
impressed with the quality of our
submission and the work of our member
training group we look forward to
welcoming the chairman of South East
employees to our next council meeting in
October when he will present us with our
award thank you Thank You leader now in
the absence of councillor Wells I call
upon councillor Fairbrass to comment on
or ask questions in relationship to the
leaders report caps the Fairbrass thank
you cheering councillor Beauford is not
quite correct in the first part of his
reports report there is a draft local
plan proposed by his administration has
been published for comment but will not
be adopted until it's been through the
Planning inspectorate's process of
examination proven sound and then
returned to this council for a vote on
adoption is not an appropriate local
plan even by his own group standards
it's clearly not fit for purpose the
airport site is not protected by a Niva
to evidence of viability because there
is no evidence for viability from any
independent source Westgate and Burton
acquire an additional I repeat
additional 1,600 homes on green fields
because of the UH neva dense Manston
element in the plan the public are now
becoming aware that what was said all
along that the supposed choice between
houses
pork was and remains a falsehood that
the promise of no night flights is an
empty one you just have to read the DCO
application of the regular night flying
that river over actually applying for
and west coast and Burrington will
suffer because of this failure to
provide any real evidence of potential
airport viability as is required by the
local plan process
Botha DCO in the local planet
examination in public are
straightforward processes based on legal
and criteria based principles and both
require evidence to support proposed
land use the Manson site remains the
unproven demonstrably on evidence
exception an exception unlikely to pass
examination commentary unscathed and the
risks of this plan remain as listed in
annex 3 to the proposal presented to us
just a few short weeks ago the public
comments will be very interesting I
should think councillor Beauford would
be correct to say that finally the local
plan plan process is moving again
whether it is moving in the right to
properly evidence direction is far less
easy to demonstrate on a happier note
can I add my congratulations to the
leaders for all the work put into the
wind the southeast employers charter for
elected member development toward it is
a commendable achievement Thank You
leader would you like to respond yeah
Thank You chairman only briefly I mean
the local plan arguments have been well
exercised and have just been repeated so
I can't see any point and continue in
that particular debate and one thing
that was missing from my report which
I've just been reminded of of course is
that since then since our last meeting
the DCO application from River Road has
been actually accepted for examination
which is progress towards the airport
that many of us want thank you thank you
I call upon councillor Reverend Piper to
comment on or ask questions in
relationship to the leaders report
councillor Piper Thank You mr. chairman
leader I'd like to begin my comments to
referring by referring to the remarks at
the end of your report and work my way
forwards so I begin by offering our
congratulations to the hard-working team
led by Nick Hughes for the wide-ranging
topics they have offered to members
for continuing development and the award
is richly deserved speaking for a moment
as a representative of a Ramsgate ward I
do hope the Select Committee for
regeneration of seaside towns and
communities find time not just to visit
something that's already being done in
Margate but to look at what needs to be
done to regenerate Ramsgate which many
feel is the Forgotten member of the
three main seaside towns that make up
Fannett and that's not to mention of
course Westgate on see Westbrook and the
village of Burlington your comments
concerning travel incursions are a sad
reflection of a group of people who
sometimes seem to pay no attention
whatsoever to the law and to the lives
of other people whom they affect
incursions are one thing but the foul
mess they leave behind and the vast
quantities of fly-tipping that they
willfully blight our green spaces with
are an indication of their complete
disregard for decency mr. chairman our
CEO often receives far more brickbats
than bouquets so on behalf of the people
of Northwood Ward and surrounding areas
and all visitors to Jackie Baker's may I
publicly thank her for taking the time
to visit Jackie bakers and for finding
the means and the money to install the
metal fencing to protect that community
asset the people around Jackie bakers
have suffered considerable nuisance due
to several incursions in the last three
years and I am of course aware of Dane
Valley and other areas but in particular
your report highlights Jackie bakers and
in particular having spent many hours
clearing up rubbish and excrement myself
after their departures I can speak from
firsthand experience about the foul mess
that these people leave behind leader
having looked at perhaps more positive
aspects I must comment on the business
of port losses to which you prefer you
refer I note that you've taken charge of
the maritime portfolio with the view to
developing a new strategic direction and
at this point leader I would like to
offer to present you with this gift
of a new pair of oven gloves at the end
of this meeting this evening because the
port is only one of several hot potatoes
you intend to pick up very shortly and
you will I believe need all the
protection you can get it is a matter of
public knowledge that a rao has erupted
between a member of the public and
officers of this council and whilst i
quite naturally agree that staff need to
be protected against vexatious
complaints and other nasty character
assertions I have to say that to some it
seems that a pattern of response is
emerging from this council that could be
described as something akin to a
sledgehammer to crack a nut and I don't
believe it's actually helping our public
image when my children were younger they
frequently asked me numerous quickfire
questions and demanded all sorts of
immediate answers and never once did I
brush them aside and describe their
questions as vexatious and unreasonable
no matter how irritated I may have been
by those questions some of the questions
being asked about the port lost his
leader and gadgets when we wind up it's
becoming its non appropriate to the
leaders response in his report he can't
respond to that I think we all feel
exactly the same and I'd like to thank
you for reminding me there's only three
months till Christmas and I better get
out soon in my Christmas shopping so if
you got something to wind up quickly can
you do so and then we'll move on to the
next leader Thank You chairman I was
going to ask if the leader would
respectfully look at the decision that's
been made or not perhaps offer a better
alternative if he's able finally then
leading you began your report by
mentioning the importance of getting a
local plan out for publication and
Thanet independent councillors are
pleased to about a hand in putting you
in a position where you were able to
lead this council to do that no local
plan will ever be perfect but perhaps
the Inspectorate will agree that this
one does offer the opportunity of good
employment prospects for our local
workforce by maintaining the Manson
Airport site for aviation and that it is
a step forward following years of
procrastination so well done but please
don't rest on your laurels just yet
those hot potatoes with confidence and
trust leader that the people will
respond positively to strategies that
improve the prospects for our sacred
isle and improve the way the council
engages with the people of thinit Thank
You Chet Thank You councillor Piper I
call upon that councillor metaphase to
comment on or ask questions oh sorry
sorry knives overlooking you there I'm
sure you'd want to respond I've
forgotten it was Christmas presents oh
I'm sorry yes leader I'm still here the
I mean generally I'm a council part
thank you for your positive comments and
the last issue it would be inappropriate
for me to both the the issue that's a
bit contentious inappropriate for me to
comment on what I would like to say
though regarding the Select Committee
visit I'm sure what very sure that the
Margate was picked as a focus because it
is an example of what you can do I mean
Margit has turned around significantly
and there are lessons to be learned but
I can assure you that in the program
that have been prepared for them they
will see the other side of the coin they
will understand by the time they go the
specific problems faced by seaside
communities and we will certainly make
the point that that's not restricted to
Margate it does cover brands get another
part of your as you say thank you leader
and apologies members for getting my
procedure wrong I now call upon council
the matter face to comment on or ask
questions in relationship to the leaders
report
councillor Mehta face Thank You chair
and councillor both would you better get
your pen out I've got some questions for
you
and my first point I want to make was a
very disappointed this report only
arrived yesterday as you are well aware
of the Constitution says we should have
had it by Saturday but I have spent time
reading it and I have come up with some
questions I'm being very pedantic here
but in your report you mentioned ongoing
losses at the port and the heart and
then you say you talk about the port so
I'm assuming you actually are quite
happy with this situation with the
harbour is just one of those issues that
they were running together so but I've
got a question about the fair
that you mentioned is this ferry which
we have been waiting for for a number of
years some of us have been around here
for a little while a member of ferry
that was coming from Australia but never
got out of Perth Harbor I believe is
this ferry proposed to be part of Kent
County Council's brexit resilience
strategy I know you make some reference
to the UK Brazilians resilience but not
specifically to Kent County Council's
you mentioned tourism and obviously
we're all very happy that our turns have
been very busy but tourism is a key
driver for economic regeneration and the
coastal communities but don't you think
there might be a danger that a cargo hub
based at Manston might have a
detrimental effect on that which is
fairly fragile truest development but we
want to see it prosper because only
referencing Wi-Fi on the beach is that
so that people can report those who were
having barbecues illegally are also
trying to get hold of a beach inspector
as we apparently seem to be remarkably
short of those it was very disappointed
when I took some visitors to Viking
Beach recently Viking Bay apologist and
the beach within reach wheelchair was
padlocked there was nobody there it was
a little note in chalk saying gone to
dumped in gap but I wasn't going to go
hurtling along to doctor gap to find
someone to come and unlock the beach
within beach beach with him Beach
wheelchair counselor pipe was already
mentioned the Select Committee can I ask
if Select Committee coming to Margate
was their choice or have we had any say
on that particular matter cuz it would
be good to know the raison d'etre behind
it and as a member of the members
Development Committee I am delighted
that we've won the Charter status we
were all sitting in the first floor last
week quite nervously not quite
rehearsing what we were going to say but
not quite sure what we were going to be
asked and I'm glad that we apparently
gave a good account of ourselves but I
would also like to thank Nick and I
would also like to thank James Clemson
because they were very much the leader
on this it was a very democratic
committee we had no chair
nobody played the prima donna but it's
good that we've got to this point and I
look forward to seeing the relevant
trophy you got to parade it around the
time so people can see it the open top
bus maybe Thank You councillor two-faced
leader would you wish to respond yes
thanks chairman I would love an open-top
bus but budget constraints councilor
matter face yeah number of questions I
know I don't know whether I've got the
mortgage but just very quickly you
talked about ongoing loss is important
harbour important harbour I'm just
talking about the whole estate that's
down at Ramsgate and we're so happy with
the harbour obviously pleased that it's
a profit but we're certain that he can
actually make a bigger one and so that's
as far as Casey seeing their resilience
planning yes we are talking with KCC
makes it a very high level and certainly
we do think there's a real strong
possibility that we will be involved in
the UK's resilience plan because Ken
it's going to be a major major factor
what happens he'll be very very
important Beach within reach I mean just
give me a chance to say what great
service that is and I share your
disappointment that it was unable
unavailable on that day as far as the
the visit by the Select Committee it was
their choice to come to us but I think
it's partly to do without will be part
of the LGI's coach of coastal special
interest group so they are aware of
what's going on here and so I think it's
because Margate now you know as
nationally recognized as a place that
you know has in places turned something
the corner not complacent there's plenty
of work to be done but yes it was their
choice and very glad that they're coming
here yeah well sorry I didn't mean to
I've got it written down I mean I think
the thing about having an airport of
münster and the driver there for those
of us that wants it is jobs that we
desperately need overall I think you
know if we do get significant number of
jobs in satanic overall that will do us
no a lot of good and I'm not so sure
that planes coming over you know they do
follow a fly the flight paths are you
except in some places there will be more
can connect I'd bits it indents you
can't count that beer no I mean yes I I
actually don't think that the impact on
tourism will be that great and I think
that if we've got a really active cargo
hub particularly as the intention in
longer term is to provide passenger
services I think that will in fact
enhance that or is an offering we will
say thank you
we now move on to agenda item 11 report
of the chairman of the executive policy
and Community Safety scrutiny oh sorry
sorry got a question
councillor messenger Thank You mr.
chairman I just wondered if I could ask
a question on the leaders report Emily
no no no point of order no you can okay
it's just the iris Johnson used to so I
just thought I mine no sorry no but
before you but after leader you did
sorry I didn't see your head no you've
raised the point of order no you can't
ask away and again Council Arkin you
know no no it's not a point of order so
we're I can't accept that I must move on
okay agenda item 11 is the report of the
chairman of the executive policy and
Community Safety scrutiny panel I call
upon council again Glenn Coleman cook to
present his report councilor common core
Thank You mr. chairman
this committee was set up in May as one
of the to scrutiny panels to maintain an
oversight on policy developments and
community safety matters this reports
largely advising this meeting of the
prep work the panel set out for the rest
of the year we've had two meetings to
date with the first being an
extraordinary meeting to consider
proposals for the draft local plan and
the second one being used mainly to plan
the work program for 2018-19
one of the key tasks of the panel is to
review the performance
to the Community Safety Partnership as
highlighted in my report in the agenda
the key topics the panel have agreed to
review our crime statistics with anis
annual crime and disorder partnership
report for 2018-19 and the annual
proposals for crime and disorder
partnership work program for 2019-20
we would also be looking at asset
management the food law service plan
enforcement policy reviewing progress on
the performance of public spaces
protection order after a six months
implementation period members further
agreed to identify topics for cabinet
member presentations during the course
of the year and I'll be inviting
different portfolio holders to panel
meetings to debate key issues relating
to policy development our main
contribution to the policy development
process to date has been the panel's
participation in debating the local plan
cabinet consulted the executive scrutiny
panel on proposals for the local plan
and I'd have to say that the debate was
robust the contributions made by the
panel with significance and
recommendations made were accepted by
the cabinet with full council later
adopting the plan I look forward to
continuing to work with cabinets and
officers to make a decision making
process stronger and would like to
invite members to take notes and comment
on the report thank you thank you
councillor Coleman cook do we worst
abate it no in that case thank you very
much we'll move on to agenda item 12 and
this is the second scrutiny panel so
this is the report of the chairman of
the finance budget and performance
scrutiny panel
I call upon councillor Linda Piper
survivor'
Thank You chairman this committee is one
of to scrutiny panels for the council
and our task is to maintain and the
oversight on the finance budget and
corporate performance of the council
this report to Council is largely
concerned with updating members on the
work the panel has planned to carry out
for the rest of this music musical you
miss appalled year sorry we make
initially on the 29th of May to consider
our terms of reference and have had two
further meetings to date one of the key
tasks of the panel will be to review
cabinet proposals for the next year's
budget the other task is to review the
performance of the council through
debating the performance report as
highlighted in my report in the council
agenda at the meeting on the 17th of
July the panel agreed to review the
following key topics proposed counsel
fees and charges for 2020 1920 the
budget 20 1920 a medium term financial
plan 20 19 to 23 the quarterly
performance reports for 2018 and 19 at
our meeting on the 30th of August we
received officer reports on the
following issues the quarter one
performance report for 2018 19 electoral
voter registration 2017 stroke 18
canvassed both reports were informative
and well presented the portfolio holder
for financial services in the States was
in attendance and engaged the panel in
positive discussions on the performance
report the panel made recommendations
concerning recording performance
measurements which we believe will be
considered favorably by cabinet and
which we hope if adopted will improve
the way the council reports its
performance the voter registration
report was equally informative members
were advised that the current voter
registration response levels were at 88%
for 2017 stroke 18 and 71% for 28 of
drunk 19 the panel made suggestions for
improving the response rate that
included adding a reminder text at the
end of the council tax letters to
residents officers agreed to investigate
this suggestion during the course of the
year the panel will identify topics for
cabinet member presentations and will be
inviting different portfolio holders to
panel meetings to debate key issues
relating to financial and corporate
performance matters I have already asked
officers to invite the portfolio holder
responsible for the port to attend the
meeting on the 23rd of October to make a
presentation on the financial and
operational performance of the Ramsgate
port and harbor officers are also
working on another panel request to get
a presentation regarding regarding
temporary accommodation for families I
look forward to continue to work with
cabinet and officers to make our
decision-making process stronger for the
benefit of our district Thank You mr.
chairman Thank You councillor Piper
councillor messenger Thank You mr.
chairman it it was really good to see
the on both overviews and scrutiny
different those different sections and
that you've got a four word plan for the
various meetings I think it'd be really
helpful to members if Democratic
services could in advance Sanders what
the cabinet member presentations are so
that they could encourage other members
to attend I'm sure that will be possible
mr. Hughes thank you I've received an
acceptance at the table so we'll look
into that possibility I'm sure it would
be most helpful to all members members
will know that when I was chairman of
overview and scrutiny I was constantly
encouraging members to attend and this
is a forum that will enhance their
encouragement hopefully I moved on now
to agenda item 13 annual treasury
management review 2017-18 I call upon
councillor Gregory Thank You chairman
this report has previously been
considered by governance and audit and
cabinet presenting this report to the
council fulfills the requirements of the
various codes of practice detailing
section 1.1 of the reports and in any
case you can never get enough of a good
treasury management report in my opinion
main points to note regarding the
overall treasury position at 31st March
this year was that general fund debts
and HR a debt were both reduced compared
to 2017 general fund capita fighter
capital financing requirement was
reduced three million pounds compared to
2017 and net investment increased from
six point three million to nine point
seven million so what's not to like
about that there was no need during the
year to revise the strategy outlined in
the original tragedy management reports
no debt rescheduling took places there
was only an average 1% differential
between the public works loan board new
borrowing rates and the premature
repayment rates all investment activity
during the year conform to the approved
strategy there was however a large
differential between both the general
fund and the HRA capital budgets and the
actual expenditure this resulted in a
reduced need to borrow as capital
slippage was available to use in the
interim the recommendation is that
council notes the actual 2017-18
Prudential and Treasury indicators in
this report and approves the annual
treasury management report for 2017 18
Thank You councillor Gregory do I have a
second I do we wish to debate councillor
messenger
thank you it's not Thank You mr.
chairman it's not really a debate it's
just really a question on page 58 of the
report the table 5 it refers to the debt
that the council has paid back it's a
really interesting table but I think it
would be more interesting if we actually
knew with which lender what the capital
program is for what they've paid back
and actually what the remaining amount
is so wonder did that could be in the
reporting future councillor Gregory are
you able to respond
yes the the loan repayments are listed
there it does as counselor messenger
says it doesn't actually say what the
loans were for I'm sure that's the
ramish over there could actually answer
that in an email perhaps to one
counselor messenger detailing what the
the loans were that were repaid as far
as what's outstanding this is concerned
I mean that is just basically our
outstanding loans anyway isn't it so
we'll know what that is
thank you I have a seconder do members
agree thank you agenda item 14 changes
to committees panels and boards 2018-19
proportionality I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect to the
options as outlined in the report leader
Thank You chairman
notwithstanding the best efforts of Nick
to confuse me by changing option one to
option 2 an option 2 to option 1 as it
meant from his initial paper to the
current one I believe that I want option
part 1 I'm proposing optional tone which
is an additional member and niceness in
which I think other leaders are happy
with this heads nodding around the
assembly so can I have a second does any
member wish to propose an alternative
option all the heads were going up and
down so thank you very much
in that case nomination to members of
members to serve on committees group
leaders may wish to take this
opportunity to advise of changes to
their nominations to committees panels
and boards for the remainder of the
2017-18 year council abhava do you wish
to advise of any nomination changes I do
chairman thank you the additional seat
on licensing will be counsel of right
due to council rush becoming a member of
cabinet she can no longer sit on on her
scrutiny panel so I'd like her to be
replaced by again
counselor right and the very industrious
Council of riot has also volunteered to
be a member of the constitutional review
working party and she served on it
before and enjoyed it so that's that's
something to be treasured and that comes
as great released accounts the game who
didn't enjoy it thank you thank you
leader and you will notice that
counselor right had both hands on the
table
at the same time during that counselor
Thea brass do you wish to advise of any
nomination changes Thank You chair no
changes Thank You Council Reverend Peter
do you thank you very much turn the page
there's more oh sorry
I keep forgetting you counselor
metaphasic I know
it's I didn't turn the page that's my
excuse
council metaphase do you wish to advise
changes no I'm not actually
after all that thank you very much
election of vice chairman election of
vice chairman of the executive policy
and Community Safety scrutiny part panel
is there a nomination counselor safe
that I believe Thank You chairman
nominate cast the Curan is there a
seconder
chairman happy to second that thank you
very much
turn the page again I didn't ask if
there are any other nominations I'm
getting carried away with myself here
tonight on time as there are no oven
candidates I declare that councillor
Curran has been elected vice chairman of
the executive policy and Community
Safety scrutiny partner panel for the
remainder of the 2018-19
year turn the page and the final thing
says
concludes the business of this meeting
of the council this evening thank you
very much for attending